ask you first of all what we've heard
from the Russian press secretary this
morning saying that your president is
not a credible man he is he does not
stand by his word and he is not a man to
be negotiated with
I understand that the historicus is very
high on both sides that because we are
still in the active phase of war the
sooner or later we will sit at the at
the table as president mentioned we will
probably do some win between Ukraine and
and Russia on the border when we will be
able with all the assistance we're
receiving right now to push the more
violence then we'll be able to discuss
how we live together for the next
centuries
uh in the last hour or so there has been
more Bloodshed here in Kiev we heard the
explosion we've been told by the mayor
that more people have died waiting for
further confirmation and details on that
um how will this War end
we believe that we will end this world
The Way We Were started we negotiated
for many many years we assigned all the
sorts of documents with Russia's
promising that we live together
peacefully all of this didn't work
probably the time has come so we'll put
everything we have and I see this change
in the mood well these tanks are
important by itself by the pieces of
equipment what is the most important
this change of Attitude Change of
behavior change of of support what else
is just just to help us go through all
this training and you know acquiring
these pieces and fighting finally I hope
that this year will be able to finish it
up and okay please be stay stay safe in
Ukraine and Kiev
uh yes thank you we have a very good
security team around us and we are
completely confident where we are at the
moment but thank you for your concern Mr
Ambassador
um the tanks are coming but will they
come quickly enough the president made
the appeal yesterday for them to come
more quickly but the particularly the
American Tax may not be here this year
but British tanks will be this is
important let's not forget we're talking
about uh German tanks but I'm quite
happy being here in London reminding
people that the first move was made by
UK because there's their own tanks they
can do it whatever they want with them I
hope that these things will arrive soon
the training the people from Ukraine to
UK will come in a month to be trained so
these things will come I hope at the
same time as leopards I'm quite happy
the chancellor promised it to have it by
the end of the March and seeing the
picture of you in in a snowy cave I
would expect that we'll need another
month or even more to start the ground
campaign
how worried are you that the Russians
are planning a new surge in the next
month or so
absolutely we understand it we expected
it that's why we're trying to
consolidate as much help as possible and
we're not talking about only these three
three nations where no we know that
around dozen Nations so already pledge
the tanks to Ukraine and I hope that our
French colleagues will also come with
their lecturics
uh we must leave it there uh thank you
very much indeed Mr Ambassador for
joining us thank you thank you